[Music]
in the summer of 2014 a streamer by the
name of Cosmo Wright made history
broadcasting out of his apartment in
Chicago Illinois he set a world record
by completing the Legend of Zelda
Ocarina of Time in 18 minutes and 10
seconds it was an incredible feat by
many standards beating a massive
adventure game like that in under 20
minutes simply doesn't make any sense to
the uninitiated but to the people who
knew him in his history with the game
cosmos record was a thing of legends by
employing a number of seemingly
impossible glitches and some incredibly
precise movement he had achieved a
near-perfect run and was able to shave
off almost a minutes worth of time from
the previous world record it was an
amazing performance by one of the
world's best speed runners but four
years prior to cosmos legendary run
something bigger was brewing something
that would change the way speed runs
were seen in the public eye and by the
people within the gaming world itself
speed running is an incredibly
fascinating niche within the gaming
world it challenges players to bend the
rules of their favorite games and to
challenge everything they know about how
they operate whether it's utilizing
glitches to skip entire areas abusing
existing mechanics or simply tearing
through the game on skill alone runners
are constantly finding new ways to reach
the credits screen pester time time
the way in which some games unravel
themselves after being split open can be
captivating experience breathing new
life into titles previously thought to
be boring or uninteresting into 2010 the
people over at speed demos archive a
website dedicated to speedrunning
brought that experience to the entire
world by gathering together volunteers
from across the country they starred
games done quick a biannual speedrun
marathon which donates all the money
they received during their week-long
live stream to charity to this date
they've raised over 10 million dollars
over the course of seven years and 15
separate events benefiting such causes
as the prevent Cancer Foundation and
Doctors Without Borders this marriage of
gaming and philanthropy is an inspiring
relationship that simply seeks to be a
positive force in the streaming world
and although games done 'quick may not
have been the first organization to
combine video games and charity their
unique take on the Union has proven to
be a successful
[Applause]
[Music]
most major gaming events in our current
age are influenced in some way by money
and to a greater extent the companies
that finance them watch any competitive
gaming event and it won't take you long
to identify the team sponsors but when
it comes to games done quick it's their
goodwill and humanitarianism that takes
center stage over product placement and
commercials there are slight nods to
their sponsors that help finance the
event but they stay true to their
grassroots origin by shining the
spotlight primarily on the people
playing the games and it's that passion
towards both the art of speedrunning and
the causes that they raise money for
that make their streams feel and daring
and their success feel earned but
charity isn't the only element of the
gaming world that speedrunning has
affected in some cases it's caused both
the players and the developers to
analyze game design more closely the
indie game dustforce is an example of
the harmony between the two parties with
its in-game timer
leaderboards and mechanics that reward
speed and precision the developers
themselves have said that they wanted to
make a game for people who cared about
mastery when players progress in
dustforce they are actually improving as
a player it's not any stats or items but
the players own ability that grows this
symbiotic relationship where the
developers are just as involved with the
game being played as the speedrunners
are is a bond that promotes growth among
everyone involved and on the other side
of that coin there are people who take
it upon themselves to dive deep into the
inner workings of the game to
deconstruct it and to break down the
barriers that separate us from the ones
and zeros in its code to me Mario Super
Mario 64 is a game that has led a
bountiful life since the 90s full of
people speedrunning the game and
perfecting its mechanics but the game
has taken on an even newer life thanks
in part to a recent exploit found that
involves what its founder calls half a
presses now the 30 minute video
explaining it gets really complex and
detailed with the narrator going on to
explain parallel universes within the
game but simply put the exploit uses a
number of glitches to have Mario build
speed over the course of 12 hours and
instantaneously launching them through
time and space to collect a level star
and although the glitch was
tool-assisted meaning the possibility of
a human recreating is next to zero it
still remains a testament to the
persistence of speedrunners and their
commitment to finding new things within
a game long after they've fallen out of
the public eye
speedrunning may typically be a solo
endeavor but if there's anything that
the countless marathons tool-assisted
runs and physics defying glitches I've
taught us it's that's also a community
effort the people taking part have
quickly turned it into something of a
fellowship one that fosters inclusion in
unity with its members in just a few
short years games done quick has
transformed into something much more
than just a speedrunning marathon it's
become a beacon of guidance for all
those interested in the craft a home for
the most weird and wonderful aspects of
gaming to be shown to the world and a
pillar upon which its members love for
both charity and video games are upheld
in champion cosmos record on that warm
July night was significant not only
because of how quickly he had beaten the
game but also because of how each
subsequent record that bested his own
echo the theme of camaraderie that the
speedrun community had established years
of for each new person to claim that top
spot benefited from the experience and
knowledge left behind by their
predecessor every new strategy or bug or
glitch
was shared with the understanding that
everyone was working towards the same
goal but speedrunning rarely if ever
feels like a competition as its appeal
goes beyond simply getting the fastest
time more than anything else it's about
challenging oneself testing one's own
endurance and ability to see the game
beyond a surface level much like the
games done quick events themselves speed
running feels less like a sprint and
more like a marathon because no matter
how fast or how slow your time is the
most important thing is that you make it
to the end with the love and support of
everyone waiting for you at the finish
line
[Music]